this is a production of Cornell
University
work there we go so I'm really excited
to share this project with you all today
especially as I'm here with plant
scientists and horticulturists and
experts in greenhouse and high tunnels
as you'll see that why that's important
to use those things to help us educate
about climate change and ultimately
we're hoping our goal is to have a
positive impact but we want to do
something a little bit different so I'm
the lucky one who gets to speak to you
today but I have two collaborators
actually have lots of collaborators on
this project and I'm going to highlight
them all at the end but here's a few of
us here at the site but heated this
effort has been Chris Wayne who has now
left the project unfortunately but we
keep drawing trying to draw him back in
as often as we can and then Josh Sarah
from landscape architecture who the
three of us served as the principal
investigators when we started putting
this project together and our cash and I
are continuing to work on this with a
host of other folks so before I tell you
about the garden itself I wanted to give
you a little background at least from
where we were working from so you have
some context for where we were coming
from and what we were trying to do and
as I think most of us are aware we
climate changes one of the biggest
challenges that we're facing and this is
a slide that I pulled from NASA when I
was initially preparing this when they
were saying that January has broken all
records that has quickly been eclipsed
by all the records set in February for
being the hottest
let me make sure I say this right the
most anomalous warm month ever recorded
so if everywhere I broke all of
January's records so we know that this
is an issue and there's lots of
scientists on campus who are working on
this but what we also know is that as
the public there's a disconnect between
the knowledge that we have about climate
change and our willingness to do
something about it
so in talking about in looking at what
other gardens were doing so plantations
as the public garden of Cornell we
wanted to know what was happening out
there a lot of work has been done on
plant conservation efforts specifically
in looking at how we conserve plants
either in Institute or exit two programs
two of the recent ones that have just
been released is the New England wild
flower Society recently put out this
habitat based approached when they
profiled their five key habitats for the
Northeast region and are discussing the
environmental issues that are facing
each habitat and discussing the impacts
of stressors such as climate change are
likely to have on those an international
organization called botanic gardens
Conservation International is looking at
climate change on plants the impacts on
plants and their ecosystems or at the
cellular level and this report lists how
the impact of climate change will affect
animals with like humans who depend on
them but also provide some
recommendations for how to stave off
extinction or to work toward these
issues that are being faced probably the
most predominant way that public gardens
are educating about climate changes
through phenology studies and looking at
things like project budburst or project
bud break and doing it in a few ways one
is by using their own plant records
which public gardens are well known to
have very detailed and accurate records
and a lot of gardens are using these
records to record the times of fresh
leaf out and the first bud break but
they're also now looking at installing
plants on a what's called a phenological
monitoring garden and looking
specifically at specific kinds of plants
and how their flowering at different
times
and then they're also involved in
citizen science efforts which train
volunteers staff school children to go
out and record the date of first bud
break or leaf break within their
communities and then the other way that
we're familiar with were our ways in
which gardens are interpreting climate
change and their outreach programs in
terms of interpretation the American
public garden Association is working to
develop a set of templates that are
based on the most recent climate science
about climate change providing
information that gardens can develop
their own interpretive tools for or
there are outreach programs such as the
community Climate Action Program at the
Chicago Botanic Garden which takes
slightly different approach and goes out
into communities and works with groups
that are traditionally not represented
in the climate change programs and they
go into the community they work with
these community groups on issues that
they're facing that are related or are
the result of climate change and look to
find assets that this community can use
to solve problems and so are really
taking it at a community level approach
and then there are educational outreach
efforts such as the Fairchild challenge
which is out of a fairchild tropical
botanic garden in Miami that is K
through 12 environmental science
competition and many of the topics that
are dressed in that through art and
literature through debates are focused
on climate change so
in looking and trying to find out if
anybody else is doing something called a
climate change garden we came across
this effort at Syracuse University and
in 2014 they installed what they're
calling a climate change garden that
will track how plants will adapt to
global warming and they planted 33
different species of trees and shrubs
some of which are adapted to Central New
York and some which are adapted to
warmer regions and they will be
monitoring these to see if there are any
changes in health and the vitality of
these species so I'll also share that
the executive director of the American
public guard association saw what we see
and feel and that is that public gardens
really are uniquely positioned to be as
he says the place to learn about and
experience climate change and that
public gardens are places where visitors
can make local connections to the global
issue and this was something that really
is something that we were very
interested in that we didn't we
appreciated the phenological studies and
the phenological monitoring gardens and
the outreach efforts in fact we're
trying to partner with the Chicago
Botanic Garden on that community-based
ask that approach that I described but
what we were looking for was something
that was demonstrative that was
experiential that was interactive I was
compelling to visitors that somehow gave
them a sense of what climate change is
expected to do and what impacts it would
have locally and in looking at this and
then going through the project for a
couple of years we recently came across
the paper from perspectives on
psychological science that was written
to address how public and gate we can
improve public engagement in policy
efforts toward climate change and just
briefly i thought i would share some of
these because they are in line with some
of the things that we're trying to do
and some of the goals that we have which
is that we value experience over
analysis so a lot of the climate science
that's put out there's a lot of what
seeing in the media a lot of the
articles that are written or even
interpretation we're seeing at public
gardens is very analytical or putting
lots of statistics out but as
individuals we do have an analytical
side of our brain but we also we react
to our gut and so if there was an
opportunity to really highlight relevant
experiences how people may be
experiencing current effects of climate
change or are seeing patterns to build
on that the other one that really jumped
out was this out of sight out of mind
and I think we may have all experienced
this in this that climate change is some
future phenomenon it's not going to
happen in our lifetime and it's
happening across the world to somebody
else other than ourselves and so how do
we make that how do we change that
perception and one of their
recommendations is to emphasize what's
happening now and what's happening at a
local and regional level and the last
one which I didn't highlight here but I
think it's really important is this idea
of how we are motivated to act and we
are either motivated at an instant fix
extrinsic level know there's some
carrots they're waiting for us or from
an intrinsic level and what their study
found is that there is this deeply held
motivation that we have intrinsically to
want to make the world a better place so
they recommended tapping into that
somehow so I don't quite figure that one
out we'll come back to that so what we
decided to do it was come up with what
we are calling a creative experiment and
it's not a true experiment in the way
that we're all used to thinking about
control and experimental but really we
wanted to figure out if we could create
a garden or some kind of experience
within a garden that would inform
visitors about climate change would
physically demonstrate what we might
expect in some future not-too-distant
future that would use plants as a lens
to communicate what these impacts are
likely to
to look like and that gave visitors some
way to really experience this and even
to interact with these changes that we
were seeing so we've came up with a way
to do this in our approach was to look
at it with from an environmental control
standpoint a plant response standpoint
and visitor response standpoint so the
environmental controls this is where
Christine came in and his love of high
tunnels he said you guys that
plantations need a high tell and so
that's kind of where we started but
really he was he was advocating not just
for us to have a high tunnel but that he
felt that it could be a tool to
approximate fuge some of the predicted
future climate conditions and then his
horticulturist and as gardeners and at a
public garden we really wanted to have
plants as the lens and wanted to see if
we could find plants that would show
effects of temperature and precipitation
and could be good communicators of what
we were expecting to see and then
ultimately we're doing this so that we
can have some impact on the visitors
that come through and you know at on a
spectrum of what we want to do from
goals that's one increasing their
knowledge of and concern of but for me
it's always about some intent to act
some making that world a better place
and I think my colleagues would agree
with that so enter the high tunnel and
we received an initial grant from the
toward sustainability foundation to buy
a high tunnel and install it and so this
is with installed it's a 24 x 20 and 12
feet high high tunnel call it covered
with a polyethylene
film and while there are lots of other
devices some far more expensive that can
approximate more accurately the effects
of climate change we were drawn to the
high tunnel because it's relatively
inexpensive and we can regulate
temperature because of the radiation and
the ventilation and that we could also
control irrigation so in addition to
constructing the high tunnel we also
constructed 12 raised beds 4 by 6 beds
both outside the garden outside the high
tunnel and inside the high tunnel and we
installed temperature sensors both
inside and outside the tunnel it's this
we are using an on-set computer model
you 30 hobo to take both the air
temperature as well as soil temperature
and measuring the active radiation
during the growing season and then what
we set out to do was to create what we
called the garden of today in the
outside bed so they would experience the
temperatures and the precipitation and
the temperature the climate changes of
today and then we wanted to approximate
some future climate and we selected the
garden of 2050 and we did this for
several reasons one is when we an
invited Jonathan Schult who is a
professor of communication to work with
us on this project he was saying you
know you really need to put a date on it
otherwise it's that future distant
future it's never going to happen date
and that date of 2050 really gives us
something not too distant that we can
understand 34 years is not that far away
hopefully many of us will still be alive
then our chill we can imagine our
children in this climate so that was one
reason the other reason is that we are
using the NYSERDA climaid report and
within this report which is full of lots
of good information but in particular
there are climate models and there
based on the 2020s the 2050s the 28th is
in the 2100 so we this timeframe gave us
a clear model to work from and this is
the report that I just mentioned and
this is an assessment that provides
information on climate change impacts
specific for New York State and even
more specifically for various regions
and we are here in turn that on as you
can see in region 3 and there are
climate projections for temperature
precipitation sea level rise heat waves
cold events intense precipitation
extreme events and storms so we were
using this purport to get at those
projections so what are they starting
with temperature that for the 2050s we
are expected to see an average annual
increase of between 4.4 and 6.3 degrees
there are expected to be an increase in
days over 90 degrees Fahrenheit up to 38
days and we're going to have a greater
frequency and duration of heat waves so
three to six consecutive days over 90
degrees or more and we're expected to
have five or three to six of those
heatwave durations lasting five or more
days and then our annual precipitation
is expected to increase by four to ten
percent now this increase right now is
looking at winter that increase will
happen primarily over the winter and
that actually in this late summer in the
fall there will be a decrease in that
precipitation and we're also expected to
have some increase in frequency and
intensity and duration of extreme
precipitation events
so looking at all those projections we
started we've installed the garden in
2014 and this is the garden itself just
to give you a sense of worth that it's
located in the botanic garden bowl of
plantations it's in what's known as the
pounder garden and it sits within the
southeast corner of that garden and we
spent the first year primarily
installing the high tunnel as I showed
you and getting the beds in and
cigarette did minimal interpretation we
were having lots of discussions about
how we would interpret it and but in
talking about the plants we were very
ambitious in his first year and we
selected six different categories of
plants to display and walk you through
those this first one it pictured here is
a temperate species that would have an
earlier and abbreviated growth period in
the high tunnel the second bed with
landscape plants that would grow well in
the high tunnel but not be Hardy outside
so the southern girl I was really
excited to see this last romeo's in
there didn't last very long and then
having more temperate species that would
have an earlier and abbreviated growth
period unusual species of tropical
origin that would grow well outside in
but not in the high tunnel no it would
grow well in the high tunnel but not so
well outside and these were things like
okra peanuts cotton Malabar spinach and
then we did a varieties of peppers
several different varieties and then
tender perennials things that would grow
well in the tunnel but not so well
outside the tunnel and this wasn't
interesting watching how people
interacted with these plants was very
interesting in this this garden at this
particular bed a couple of anecdotes
both for myself and for the student
who's working in there is that when
people saw this they were like climate
change bring it on I can grow this here
now
we're really excited so this one we're
talking about plants as messengers a
little bit later we always come back to
this one about being being clear about
what kind of message we're trying to
convey and then this is the
interpretation we had for the first year
which was very simply a welcome sign
mentioned a little bit about the garden
in what we were trying to do there we
did have a brochure with a detachable
survey and invited folks to walk around
and into our idea is that they would
interact with the garden and tell us a
little bit about what they felt about
the quality of the plants inside and
outside so the flip of this had an
inside the tunnel and asked them to rank
and then have these directed questions
and we put out a hundred surveys they
were all gone at the end of the season
but we only received nine of these
detachable surveys back and from that we
saw that these open-ended questions
didn't work so well people did tend to
fill in the the quality but not so much
on the on the open-ended questions and
then we had staff or are we've had
several interns work in the garden and
they documented their observations both
about the garden but also about the
visitors that were there in the kinds of
questions and interactions that they had
so there were a couple lessons that we
learned from this first year that we've
taken we took them on to for this last
year in 2015 and so as I mentioned it
was we really were getting started
planting the garden seeing how well it
would work what we did see is that in
the high tunnel we were able to get even
though it was not severely restricted in
terms of the ventilation we were able to
get an increase in the temperature
higher inside the tunnel than outside
the tunnel and we also observed
differences in plant growth inside and
outside and I just mentioned to you
about the visitor survey results or lack
thereof that we got
and but also probably one of the most
striking things was how people use the
site or didn't use the site and out the
chart so this is where that sign was
that the interpretive sign and with the
brochure but in order to get into the
garden you either had to go up this step
walk around this planting of corn and
bypassed the high tunnel which everybody
wants to walk into it first or you had
to enter from some other part of the
garden or jump up off this probably two
feet retaining wall so it we weren't
really able to direct the experience and
how people move through it and there
wasn't a lot of signage that said this
was the garden of the day this was the
garden of 2050 so enter what we did last
year which was to improve the visitor
experience and go into that first so
this is a fairly accurate rendition of
that was done by Maroon Akbar who is a
student in landscape architecture to
really help us redesign the experience
so that visitors understood what they
were coming into and what they were
seeing and with the exception of this
arch which isn't in the garden we did
install some new steps that people could
come directly into the garden and then
we displayed a sequence of interpretive
messages along with we call focused
information tags in the garden and just
to give you a sense of what that look
like here at this first space and this
is what it looked like as you walked up
to it we tell you a little bit about the
garden itself a little bit more about
some of the science behind it what we're
hoping to do in the garden very clearly
say this is the garden of today and this
is the garden of 2050 and give you some
of those graphics that another student
in landscape architecture helped us
develop to convey some of this
information which if you read it in a
paragraph it's pretty hefty but she
worked really hard with us to
graphically depict that so it was more
visible especially when you look at some
of the interpretation which studies that
say most people spend maybe two minutes
if we're lucky looking at a sign
so then before they enter the garden we
wanted to stop them and tell them a
little bit about the plants that would
be seeing in these gardens and when I
mentioned we were very ambitious about
the plants that we had in the first
year's garden what we one of the things
that our students saw and her
observations is that it was very
daunting there were lots of plants to
look at and the messages and doing the
comparison between six different
categories and what ended up being 36
different plants was pretty overwhelming
so we narrowed it down to two categories
of plants nectar resource plants and
vegetables and grains and then we tell
them a little bit about why we're
interested in looking at these plants
and then we tell them a little bit about
but there are these what we call we call
them focused information tags we're
trying to call out something or draw
their attention to something or get them
to interact and then when they get to
the back of the garden before they enter
into the garden of the future we wanted
to give them a chance to record some of
their observations so this is one of
those
and then before they enter into the high
tunnel we tell them about what they're
about to enter into so again we're using
some of those graphics that were
developed say what does the garden of
2050 look like what are you expected to
encounter and then we have this
chalkboard where we can call attention
to what is happening within the garden
and so at this particular time we were
initiating a heatwave trying to trying
to initiate a heatwave we are we tried
to be six follow the projections and had
six heat waves over the course of the
2015 season and then finally as they
accept exit the garden we wanted to give
them some another opportunity to share
their observations so things like this
and then give them a little up give them
some way to learn about more about the
garden and then we gave them a takeaway
brochure which is based in large part on
the work that David Wolfe did in his
chapter about gardening sustainably in a
changing climate he was very generous
with this work to give our visitors
something that they could leave with
that gave them some tools to do more so
the other thing we tried to do in
addition to improving the visitor
experience was really to tune the tunnel
and in this case we didn't get quite the
increase that we were looking for in
2014 that was consistent with the
projections for 2050 so we really wanted
to figure out how we could tune that
tunnel to get the temperature increase
the average annual temperature increase
of four point four to six point three we
also installed in 2014 we were manually
rolling up the sides of that high tunnel
to restrict the ventilation to get the
temperatures up and last year we
installed so you see there's the manual
and when you have to do a couple of
times a day it's not hard but it gets
its to be a lot of work so we installed
some we automated them and I'll talk a
little bit about that automation in a
few minutes and then we really wanted to
figure out and test and identify plants
that could be our messengers and whether
they were susceptible to the impacts
that we were seeing with climate change
or if they were showing resilience to
them and looking at how they would be
affected by temperature and eventually
precipitation whether they had
accelerated growth or senescence bloom
time differences stressor to our stress
related diseases and could we interpret
those in a way that our visitors would
understand and that we could attribute
to temperature or precipitation and
change in precipitation or temperature
so as I mentioned we focused on grain
crops and we want what we wanted to do
is tie the this idea of the food food is
going to our food plants are going to be
affected by climate change in some cases
we know how but in some cases we don't
know how so we thought we would start
with grains since so much of our diet
it's based on grains and then we would
have other plants that are common in
home gardeners home gardens so in these
beds here we have barley wheat and oats
and what we we know about at least with
wheat is that it's a short-lived annual
and under increased temperatures it
could grow faster and have reduced
yields and so that's something that we
could interpret in this case last year
we had some disease that affected the
the wheat and we don't know again why
this was the case but this is something
this is something that we're trying to
tune in terms of understanding it we
also tried beans in the garden both
inside and outside and
mentioned that we went through six heat
waves and when these beans are setting
their flowers we had one of those heat
waves and so what we ended up seeing was
a split set of the beans which so we
have beans of different sizes because at
higher temperatures the beans will drop
their flowers which for a home gardener
may not be a big deal but from a
production standpoint could have a real
impact in having see the fruit of
different sizes and both the grains and
the beans were done relatively early in
the season so it gave us an opportunity
to try out another set of crops so we
tried out lettuce and we had different
germination rates inside and outside of
the garden so we're recording those and
this is a different set of varieties of
lettuce that were planted in the bean
beds and then for the other final food
crop we had peppers and wanted to see
what kinds of differences we could
expect there then the other set of plans
for our nectar resource plants and we
did this by early blooming flowers late
blooming summer flowers and then fall
blooming flower so this is the early
summer flowering plants things like iris
versicolor the menorah of the pentam and
wanted to see what kind of impact that
they would have and this was another way
that instead of just pointing out things
we were asking for visitors to comment
on their observations and with the
exception of the first set of checks in
both of these which is us putting it on
there so people know what to do you can
see that our visitors generally
recognize the difference between what
they were seeing inside and outside
and then these are the late summer
flowering plants so two different
varieties of sleepiest and pike anthem
and again trying to draw attention to
what we were seeing and help our
visitors see that so here we're asking
them to count the flowers inside and
outside see if they can notice a
difference and then finally we had the
fall blooming plants so we had solid a
go Cleo knee and a common would asked
her and in this case excuse me we had
this pork leoni that was being over
competed by the solidago and we simply
say here this Clowney is having a hard
time competing plant communities in the
future may change as some plants better
adapt to new conditions so the other
thing that we did last year was to in to
work with Jonathan schult from
communication to really get serious
about a visitor survey we saw
limitations of our initial one and we
wanted his help and his work is working
with public perception of climate change
and he's a statistician and so lots of
good things to offer and what we did
with this visitor survey is that we
asked some general questions about
knowledge people's knowledge their
concern their opinion about climate
change and how it's caused when the
changes will occur and the likelihood
that they would take some action and all
of these questions are based on previous
on polling data whether it's Gallup poll
or ABC News polling times polling and
this is so that we can we can use our
results and we can compare them to
what's being pulled on a national level
we also then asked some very specific
questions to our project things about
what impact we would have on local plant
communities those nectar resource plants
the local crops what people can expect
in 2050 to are they recognizing the
changes that were likely to see
what is it what is going to happen
specifically in central New York wanted
to understand if they had they felt like
they had access to reliable information
and then if they were seeing any
differences between the plants inside
and outside and whether the signs that
we had up were of help and so our
initial results just saying that this
was a pilot test we didn't launch it
till the very end of the season we only
had forty-three percent participants and
most of those were students from
communication so they were had incentive
to participate we also had tour takers
folks who came on tours of plantations
who were willing to do it and with that
with only having 43 participants we
don't have as Jon says not enough
statistical power to say anything but he
was and these are his words initial
indications are that there's something
detectable happening so he was very
encouraged by what he was seeing but he
wouldn't say anything more than that for
this act but he's on board for us to do
this next season so talking about that
and what we plan to do we are again
working on refining what we're doing
we're not really changing the plant
material very much we want to refine
that garden experience in looking at the
interpretation and how people navigate
through the garden and we want to see if
we can find tunes to end the tunnel and
whether we can eventually replicate this
so in terms of the garden and the tunnel
one of the things that Josh was
successful in doing was partnering with
a professor from the Department of
biological and environmental engineering
Pete marketo who is working with us to
build as best I can call it a widget
that will take the temperature from that
computer sensor the weather station and
monitor what's happening outside
no what we want to have happen inside in
terms of average annual increase but
also these heat waves and it will take
all that information and it will do what
we want and he's told us that we can
even have a heatwave button on this so
that the side the sides of the tunnel
and the vents and the doors can be
automated to ventilate the tunnel to
have the kind of controls that we're
looking for to meet the projections that
we're hoping to replicate the other
thing we're trying to do is once we get
that temperature dialed in is to figure
out how we can start to include
precipitation so right now we've only
been working under one the one variable
of temperature and seeing if we can
raise the temperature in the high tunnel
enough to meet what's being projected
and to see what kind of impact that will
have on plants but we know that
precipitation is going to be a big issue
for plants and so we're talking about
how we might do that with soil sent
moisture sensors but also with hand
watering and drip irrigation and things
of that nature we really want to get the
plants right we are trying to as I said
use plants as messengers and we want to
make sure that the plants that we're
using will have some effect and that
that effect is the result of either
temperature precipitation and that they
are have the ability to be observed and
that we can interpret that observation
so this is something that we're
continuing to work on and certainly if
you have suggestions or comments about
how some which plants might do well our
teams already been talking with folks
like Thomas bjorkman and looking at
broccoli perhaps because of its the
effect the temperature can have on it
and then we're also really wanting to
look at how we can have that impact on
visitors
if we if we're having an impact what is
it and why to what extent and if we're
not having an impact why not and what
can we do to change that so we are as i
mentioned really aiming for a more
robust sampling of our visitor survey of
the visitor surveys but what we also
like to do is to do some visitor
observations of how people are in the
garden what kinds of questions they have
are they making observations if we're
able to do some interviews with visitors
we'd like to get that qualitative data
as well as the visitor data survey data
and ultimately what we'd like to do is
to figure out if this is a project that
we can replicate that other gardens or
other organizations can do their gardens
relatively inexpensively and have the
same kind of impact for their region and
use this as a tool to help visitors
understand about climate change and so I
just want to share some words of thanks
i mentioned Josh and Chris at the
beginning but there's a host of other
folks who are working on this project
with us to folks like Donna levy who is
going to be managing the garden for us
this season sarah Fiorello who really
has been instrumental in helping us with
the interpretation for this program the
gentleman there on the bottom your left
is Jonathan Schult from communication
and then Nina basak and David Wolfe have
also been agreed to work with us and
collaborate with us on the project to
really help us understand some of these
things that we're still looking to
figure out things about plants what
effect that we're having on plants and
and what's the reason for that effect
and some of these irrigation issues so
we have great meeting last week and are
very excited to have them working with
us on this and then there are a host of
folks at Cornell plantations who you
know without him we wouldn't have this
program either they are out there
installing this garden helping us find
plants sourcing the material and then
we've had a host of really phenomenal
graduate students people like Emily
wrote occur
and Julie Romeo all des I don't have a
picture of who was the young woman who
did all those graphics that I was
showing you and then Mike Roberts who is
also an employee at plantations but he's
now working on a master's in looking at
climate change so this is not a
one-woman show except for today and then
I just want to recognize the support
that we've gotten financially from the
toward sustainability foundation the
Atkinson center for sustainable future
Cornell plantations and the Department
of landscape architecture who made this
possible so with that I will end and be
happy to take any suggestions or
questions or comments that you might
have yeah no actually good crucially
looking at the plans it looks like
plants did better in the panel when they
did have some fun I think this is really
the choice of plants is really going to
be critical and act one of the things
like you mentioned that jumped out at me
is iris versicolor is a obligate wetland
plant you might want to take that out
it's a it's not going to be it's a
wetland plant and so you're in a
situation where probably won't do better
in either a larger issue yeah so just
something I've been thinking about those
plants that really i'm going to show
what you want just looking at it says
hey they did better in the tub right in
this is some of that the visitor
observation that we had
and I mean I picked those photos to show
the plants there are other photos that
showed the opposite of that but if
you're going through a garden on that
particular day that's how it looks like
and that's what says we have that effect
work with the all of those tropical
plants were like oh this is cool bring
it on right so how are you feeling the
frame so I so we have a water gauge
outside measures rainfall and what we've
been doing is it as fluttering the same
amount inside the tunnel so we have a
gauge on the hose that Lars so that
we're at this point keeping this one
wished are equivalent in both outside
and inside water something you might not
be watering hole well before it is a big
part right and this just recently came
up that when your hand watering here
you're cooling the plants right by and
your gun on the foliage and how we're
doing that so what we were discussing
last week is putting it your irrigation
there that would be all the better and
we might even be able to control up and
make sure the 30 their equivalent you
want to keep them equivalent we can do
that but if we want to say okay heatwave
and the drought then we can the cold
water
praying to me sunny is similarly in
terms of the plant material selection
we've selected plans for inside the high
tunnel that have a warmer range in
general might you also have a set of
plans that are typically found in more
cooler ranges you know just show them
being heat stress in that future
scenario right so that the plants that
we had in the 2014 season had that we
had some that would show stress under
cooler temperatures that would make the
winter because they would also have
clients that were more temperate here
more adapted to this climate but in the
second season we didn't go to that
extreme in terms of having all those
different kinds of plants but it's it's
a constant conversation that we're
having about how to evolve especially
with the plant material and our week not
only telling the story of how things are
going to be adversely affected but we
also be telling the story about
resilience and how we're going to have
to adapt to this at some level and so
maybe we bring in some of these plants
that are being bred for warmer
temperatures and how my our farmers are
for season here in converter I know that
a goal of the garden close in terms of
plan James interpretive signage is to
increase awareness among visit public of
the reality and seriousness of climate
change
typically an even higher goal is to move
visitors to action so as any of the
future interpretation or if you address
actual actions that people can take we
have left the ideal and villa good have
right now that's doing that is the
brochure which provides information as I
mentioned from David's chapter that
gives gardeners the tool there how to
adapt their garden or things that they
can do to mitigate using their garden
for the climate change because some of
our future blue sky discussions have
been having another high tunnel and
showing how you might adapt thinking
about where things you might mitigate in
your garden and what impact that has
you'd mentioned that you know there's
some hope that this serves as a model
that can be used in other gardens I'm
curious if you have heard of them they
had other gardens contacted you about
this program or have you had an
opportunity to present this model where
you waiting to fine-tune it before doing
that a very good question and no we
don't we don't really want to wait any
part there's part of as would want to
make sure it's good but we also want
that feedback in terms of what other
gardens are likely to do so something
that resident work well for them they
have the space and it had the funds even
at relatively expensive hi Colin still
ten thousand dollars and plus all the
other comp
beds but we were the American public art
association they're aware that we're
doing this and they're serving as a
clearinghouse for others who are
interested in so through them I've been
contacted quite a bit by other gardeners
and in fact was invited to speak at last
summer's Botanic Gardens Conservation
International about this project was a
big hard climate about how gardens can
educate about climate change and then I
would be presenting at this summer's
APGA seminar the there's ten we were
invited to participate in to grant
programs about climate change in
education and that this would be a model
that we would be sharing and I've been
talking with other gardens about so keep
our fingers crossed those notes and
they're also with being article that
Sonja has authored up by the change
garden in the next issue of public
garden matter
experience with the state was with the
widget that's monitoring and I wouldn't
Pete's class last night which we sort of
a loose collective of students working
on that feather what i know pete has
left the taking a new job so I just
curious way right right well thank you
because the reports were getting in that
up quite understanding that's why I
called with it yeah I've heard about is
like was sure how it works but sounds
very exciting how men Pete Josh really
understand it to Pete although he's left
to go to another position he's still in
town we're actually meeting website
later this month for us to figure out
how to install it so along its
electrical power but we'll have a solar
panel that will power it so we can walk
the walk with what we're trying to do as
well and hopefully it will be installed
by the end of april and then we'll be
using it for the season Gaskin Axia you
can help us interpret it well I want to
thank sonya for a fascinating seminar I
think we all need to make the track down
the hill to see the climate change guard
in the scroll of the season this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu